thanking everyone again for your
patience and for the sacrifices
that you've been making businesses pubs
restaurants that have been waiting to
welcome customers back through their
doors
grandparents who have gone for months
without seeing their grandchildren
weddings postponed funerals sadly
constrained and religious festivals
such as eid yet again facing
restrictions
and i want to thank you particularly
because your efforts
have so visibly paid off giving us the
time
to vaccinate more than two-thirds of all
adults across the uk
with more than one-third nearly 18
million people
also receiving their second dose
and thereby unquestionably saving
many lives and so it's precisely because
of your efforts that i can
confirm today that we've met our four
tests
for further easing the lockdown in
england and
chris will run through the details in a
minute but with
deaths and hospitalizations at their
lowest level since last july
the the uk's four chief medical officers
today
agreeing a reduction in the alert level
the data now support
moving to step three in england from
next monday
the 17th of may this means the rule of
six
or two households that has applied
outdoors
will now apply indoors and the limit for
outdoor meetings will increase
to 30 from next monday you'll be able to
sit inside a pub
and inside a restaurant you'll be able
to go to the cinema
and children will be able to use indoor
play areas
we're reopening hostels hotels
bmbs we'll reopen the doors to our
theaters concert halls and business
conference centers we'll unlock the
turnstiles of our sports stadia
subject to capacity limits and from next
week
everyone will be able to travel within
britain
and stay overnight meaning schools will
also be able to organize
trips with overnight stays
we will no longer require face coverings
in classrooms
or for students in communal areas in
secondary schools and
colleges all remaining university
students will be able to return to
in-person teaching where they should be
tested
twice a week we will increase the number
of named visitors
for those in care homes from two to five
and residents will have greater freedoms
to leave their home without having to
isolate on their return
this unlocking amounts to a very
considerable step on the road back
to normality and i am confident that
we will be able to go further
subject to the impact of step three on
the data we remain
on track to move to step four on the
21st of june
and to give business more time to
prepare we'll be saying
more later this month about exactly what
the world will look like and what role
there could be
if any for certification and social
distancing
and today we're taking a step towards
that moment
when we learn to live responsibly with
kovid
when we cease eventually to rely on
detailed government edicts and
make our own decisions based on the best
scientific advice about
how to protect our families and those
around us
so from next monday we're updating the
guidance
on close contact between friends and
family
setting out the risks for everyone to
make
their own choices this doesn't mean we
can suddenly
throw caution to the winds in fact
more than a year into this pandemic we
all know
that close contact such as hugging is a
direct way
of transmitting this disease so i urge
you
to think about the vulnerability of your
loved ones
whether they've had a vaccine one or two
doses
and whether there has been time for that
vaccine
to take effect remember
outdoors is always safer than indoors
and if you're meeting indoors remember
to open a window
and let in the fresh air keep getting
tested regularly
even if you don't have symptoms so you
don't spread the virus
without knowing it and whatever you
decide
i must ask you to continue to follow
social distancing when not with friends
and family
including in workplaces shops pubs
restaurants and other settings
we only have to look at the very sad
situation in other countries to see
the lethal potential still of this virus
and we must continue to fight the spread
of variants
here in the uk while we have
no evidence yet to believe that these
variants
are completely vaccine resistant we must
remain vigilant so
please remember hands face space
and fresh air and as we mark
mental health awareness week perhaps
also
take a moment to check in on friends and
family
and see how they are doing after all
that we have been through
together or if you're struggling
yourself
get the support that you need
today we are announcing
the single biggest step on our roadmap
and it will allow us to do many of the
things
that we've yearned to do for a long time
so let's protect these gains
by continuing to exercise caution
and common sense